at a courthouse in virginia one of
hollywood's ugliest and most enduring
legal battles is rolling into town
behind the curtain actor amber heard
travelling to another court date with
her ex-husband one of film's biggest
stars
mr depp
how are you feeling
he may be feeling buoyant for now but
bruising weeks in court await mr depp
he is suing over this article written by
ms heard in which she recounts her
experience as a survivor she says of
sexual violence
johnny depp isn't mentioned by name but
he says it's plainly about him his
lawyer explaining why he's seeking 50
million dollars in damages
for nearly 30 years
mr depp built a reputation as one of the
most talented actors in hollywood today
his name is associated with a lie a
false statement uttered by his former
wife
the defendant amber heard
that falsely cast mr depp
falsely
unfairly characterized
cast mr depp as a villain
ms heard in turn is counter suing for
100 million dollars she says she was
physically emotionally and sexually
abused during their tumultuous
relationship
it takes eight to ten tablets of ecstasy
almost immediately and the next three
days are just a cycle of a very very
very violent
activity by him
he rips off her nightgown he has her
jammed up against a bar he has hurled
bottles and bottles at her she has
dragged her across the floor on the
broken bottles in the liquor
you may have a sense of deja vu and
that's because what we've heard today
and what we'll hear for the next seven
weeks is very familiar it's similar to a
court case in london in 2020 in which
johnny depp was suing the sun newspaper
for libel he lost that case the judge
deciding that there was enough evidence
to support their description of him as a
wife beater
this trial is the sequel another attempt
at reputation damage limitation and
despite more grisly details of his
private life many of depp's fans are
standing by him martha calmer sky news
virginia